it's very important for the child to lie
on the father's chest skin to skin
contact how much of this is throw
science and how much of this is legit
absolutely legit there's one thing I
will tell a father after birth is put
that baby on your chest the reason for
that is human babies are sensory beings
like a lot of little baby mammals their
senses are very heightened one of the
senses that's not heightened is Vision
but they are amazing at smelling they're
amazing at feeling and touch so if you
put them on your chest as a father first
of all they smell you they start to
smell who you are because they can't
really see you secondly a wonderful
thing called biobehavioral synchrony
happens when you put a baby on your
chest their physiology starts to go into
time with your physiology so they'll
come to the same temperature as you
their heart rate will come to the same
heart rate as you their blood pressure
will come to same blood pressure as you
also touch is the key release of bonding
hormones oxytoce and dopamine b-trend
orphan if you want to release those the
best thing you can do is use touch and
it's really critical as the first
interaction between a father and child